first we begin in North Las Vegas where
people there are pressing officers for
answers North Las Vegas seeing several
fatal shootings and wrecks in the last
month and tonight we hear from their
police captain who says crime is not on
the rise 8 news now reporter Madison
Kimbrough is live near headquarters with
the latest Madison
Denise Captain Hyde joined his
Department in their quarterly Community
Connection meeting and residents didn't
hold back
hearing the gunshots you know we're
seeing the crime happen Diana Ramirez
wants to know what officers are doing
about violence in her neighborhood and
when there will be more feet on the
street and the response time has been
locking because we're short staffed with
you know officers Captain Adam Hyde with
North Las Vegas PD admit 16 homicides
this year is unsettling but it's
actually in line with numbers from the
last two years due to the fact that the
children are all out of school we do see
an uptick with a juvenile crime overall
the crime is very consistent between
2023 at this time 22 and 21. statistics
don't mean much when just last week
three teenagers were shot outside of a
convenience store 19 year old Dwayne
Edwards was killed and officers blame
gang violence and although the captain
stressed overall crime isn't climbing
residents don't feel safe crime in our
community I think needs to be kind of
thwarted as much as possible but help is
on the way as the Department's
recruitment efforts are paying off we
just uh least 10 officers today from
field training so that is more officers
on the streets and more officers for our
citizens in North Las Vegas and while
many residents left Tuesday night's
meeting feeling informed for Diana the
need for trust and transparency are
still missing hopefully the police
department continues to try to build
that bridge between the residents and
their Department because there is a lot
of animosity
officers are still looking for a suspect
in the triple shooting that killed
Dewayne Edwards meanwhile the captain
tells me that he believes the police
department is more engaged than ever
before live in North Las Vegas Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now